my buddy Brett Farve here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Brett I'm good
rich I'm good so much great talking with
you I've seen right right right right
back at you so what when you think about
the Bears in the rivalry and your memory
would be what super competitive
hard-nosed anything is possible
throw the records out the window you
know the the unpredictability of the
game you know the last game as a packer
that I played against against the Bears
was was the year in which we we lost a
championship game to the Giants and we
played I think it was the day or two
days before Christmas we played at at
Soldier Field Chicago into the Year 3
and 13 of course we end up with a much
better record and almost made it through
coal but true to form we had everything
to play for they had you know one foot
the parking lot so to speak it was the
coldest game I think in Soldier Field
history still today and we played as if
we had nothing to play for and we have
one foot park hot and they absolutely
just pounded us and I attribute that to
to the to the rivalry itself so if you
just never know in this this rivalry and
just think of all the great players that
have played against each other in this
rivalry in dating back to you know way
longer than we've been alive well I've
got Urlacher on at the top of our number
two what was it like scanning the
defense in scene 54 on the other side
well it was always a chess match
obviously O'Brien's athletic ability was
superior to really anybody at his
position his skill set was was totally
different than anyone else you would
face and and he was extremely bright so
not only did you have to sound smart him
but she had to be precise trying to get
the ball over
down the middle and their Tampa to
defense was what was very tough to do
and not many guys could do that and so
you know you go okay we'll throw it
under it and that was equally as hard
his skill set was just just so good that
getting a blocker up on him in the
second level was was easier said than
done
on paper there's a lot of things you
could do against him in that defense but
when it came down to actually executing
it it was it was a much different story
so now obviously Bradley player we all
know we all know Brett you're a
Mississippi guy and you were acquired by
the team from Atlanta oh did anybody
have to sit you down or or tell you
about the significance of playing the
Bears before you first did in Green Bay
no you know what I was actually
listening to NFL Network last night they
had Mike Singletary on it and I echo a
lot of things he said and that question
was posed to him and and much like I
would answer it you know you you sort of
learn very quickly from mostly the elder
statesmen either on the team presently
or you know like in my case rate Nikki
and Max McGee and and a fair amount of
guys still lived in the area and it it
seemed like the first conversation you
had with them always ended up talking
about the Bears and which I thought was
kind of weird you know like why the
Bears but so it was kind of edged in
your mind right away and and I guess
that just kind of stays with you and
then you you then in turn become the
elder statesman and you relay that to
the younger generation and it just kind
of falls in line and when you when you
played them I mean did you ever then
become that guy who would tell new
Packers hey let's circle this one folks
this is pretty big to everybody around
here did you then become that you
I I did do that as well as others I you
know when when Barrett week was getting
close you know I would much like the
playoffs and veteran players will say
that to the younger group when
approaching the playoffs it's a much
different game the you know the speed is
greater you know and and all that I
guess to a certain extent is true but
from a rivalry standpoint it was
unmatched by by any other so you kind of
heightened the awareness with it for the
younger me did it just was like first
half practice you come out bare week and
it was like it was like the first day of
practice ever you were you were running
around you were fired up where you're
excited about whatever the game plan was
and it just brought a you know
heightened an overly heightened sense of
excitement than it would any other week
a couple more minutes with Brett Farr
that's one just one yeah you know this
opens the entire season and the a
hundred-year you know means so just this
brings even more of a special meaning
doesn't it though I mean doesn't it
though I did you ever barked at Ditka or
him back at you you got a good story
like that from this rivalry you know I
was always fighting him I was afraid at
65 he kicked my ass and he probably
would have so you know there's some that
you don't provoke yes Warren Sapp was
one Urlacher was another when Reggie
White was one of course Mike Ditka was
up was even even in his retirement older
age you did not provoke him I bet I bet
hey there's gonna be a lot of
reminiscing Brett here in the NFL 100
season in so many moments that you have
provided I gotta ask you to pick one if
you could pick one say this is the one
I'm gonna give to NFL Films is the one
I'm gonna give to NFL Network this is
the one I'm gonna give to everybody
that's talking about memories from my
career the thing that I want people to
remember that I did and I know again
you're a team God but your moment would
be
in this NFL 100 season Brett Favre in
regards to this rivalry no overall your
entire career that puts you in Canton oh
boy you know I said tell us when I when
I was you know would have to go with the
game which I played like you know after
my father died just because of the you
know the circumstances and and really
there was only one one all just one
option really for me and playing in that
game and that was the play better than
I'd ever play in my life and and I was
able to achieve that and honor my father
which was my only goal in that game I
was amazing Brett I mean are you we're
again before I let you go back to your
golf game are you aware of the people
you touched on that night I don't you
know yes and no I know people still talk
about it and and I'm honored that they
do obviously I wish the circumstances
were much different but but I am I'm
extremely grateful for the outpouring of
of compassion that that the just fans in
general whether you were a fan of mine
for the Packers or like in that case
that night the Oakland Raiders fans but
when my name was called out gave me a
standing ovation and I've said this I
said my whole same speech they don't do
that for anyone and to honor me and my
father that way was was very special and
the last time last one for you Brett
last time you got a call to us kick the
tires on whether you'd want to play
football again when was the last time
that happened oh I must say probably
eight years ago seven years ago no
kidding I guess I'm you know I'm a
little too bright now do you remember
which team it was that was the last one
to call you seemed like it was the Rams
or somebody like that I forgotten but
it's been long enough that obviously I
forgotten okay hey Brett go back go
ahead it how'd you do how do you on the
front what does your game look like
these days
absolutely suck come on come on we're
playing we're playing great course
mobile Country Club me and my brother
and three buddies we play somewhere
every week at least once okay I'm not a
big golf I used to be and so we're we
just trying to play displaces and we're
playing at great golf course mobile
Country Club right now okay
modern Hill okay and so are you giving
it are you giving out strokes or what
are you doing receiving strokes what are
you what is it right now was this game I
refuse to take strokes I got too much
pride I probably should take strokes
because in the end I always fork over a
little money I don't bet a lot okay so
I'm pretty tight with my money sure but
you know it's feast or famine with me I
play about as much as I put forth effort
no I don't practice button and therefore
I don't make any push well at least we
gave you ten minutes of a reset here go
out get your mind right get straight and
usually people who appear on the rich
eyes and show get a bump of some sort I
have a feeling you're gonna have a grab
the next nine sounds great Bert Brett
thanks for calling bud okay rich always
great talking we're right back at you
you are the best that's Brett Farr for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app